bonsoir nous sommes le 3 janvier
bienvenue sur TVfil 78 si vous nous
rejoignnez en direct à 18h pour une
nouvelle édition du 78 rendez-vous
quotidien sur l'information des Yvelines
ce soir il sera question du handicap
journée mondial du braille demain
vendredi des bénévoles de l'association
Valentin à dont une professeur de braay
nous en diront plus et puis handicap
moteur et vie sexuel le sujet est tabou
l'Association des Paralysés de France
dans les ivelines a choisi de développer
un programme pour défendre ce droit déjà
en plateau pour débuter cette émission
Yve vandeval bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président du conseil général des
Yveline UMP le Grand Paris Express pas
assez ambitieux c'est en substance ce
que vous dites c'est votre analyse sur
le rapport aux années commandé par le
gouvernement le gouvernement qui doit
rendre sa décision sur ce Grand Paris
sur ce super métro le 15 février quel
délai quel budget et puis quel trajet
également nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure nous sommes jeudi le jeudi c'est
aussi le jour de la chronique de l'cho
bonsoir Alice bonsoir Wilfried avec vous
dans une vingtaine de minutes oui
exactement alors nous parlerons de ces
entreprises en difficulté qui peuvent
recevoir une aide gratuite et bénévoolle
de la part d'avocat expert comptabl ou
encore juges du tribunal de commerce
nous verrons tout cela avec notre invité
à tout à l'heure donc sans plus attendre
les titres en image à présent les sujets
à découvrir au cours de cette édition
les chiffres de la population entré en
vigueur au premier janvier 2013 ils
viennent d'être publié par l'INC sur une
année à noter que le nombre d'habitants
dans l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yveline est en légère baisse il est
stable pour l'ensemble du département un
séjour intergénérationnel proposé par le
Secours populaire des Yvelines le
premier du genre pendant une semaine une
quinzaine de personnes jeunes comme
moins jeunes a rejoint la Savoie pour
passer les fêtes de fin d'année à la
neige des fruits frais en guise de
posuse détente depuis 8 ans les vergers
de Gali livre des paniers de fruits dans
les entreprises aujourd'hui la socicié
qui était enregistre un millier de
clients dans les ivelines elle travaille
jusqu'à Paris et puis une fête peut en
chasser une autre vous le savez après
Noël le Nouvel An voici venu le temps de
l'épiphanie les boulangers s'activent
pour préparer leurs galettes comme le
veut la tradition la franyane remporte
les succès reportage dans une pâtisserie
de la verrière et puis cette information
également le départ du recteur de
l'académie de Versailles Alain boissinau
nommé en 2004 et il dit avoir sollicité
ce remplacement il était temps de passer
la main c'est ce que rapporte L'Express
sur son site internet L'Express qui
annonce également qu'alin boissinau
aurait refusé le poste de secrétaire
général du ministère de l'Éducation pour
se voir confier une mission sur les
questions universitaires pour le
replacer dans l'académie pierre y duvoie
le directeur de du cabinet du ministre
de l'Éducation Vincent payon une
surprise ce dernier étant l'un des
principals artisans du texte de la
réforme de l'éducation et qui devrait
être présenté dans les prochaines
semaines plus d'informations dans nos
prochaines éditions Yv vendeval
peut-être une réaction action sur ce
départ d'in boissinon que vous avez
forcément côtoyé he pendant les 9 ans
d'exercice bien sûr c'est d'abord une
longévité tout à fait exceptionnel à ce
poste et je crois que c'est un recteur
notamment qui a accompagné la croissance
de l'Université de versaill
Saint-Quentin qui est il faut le dire
une magnifique réussite c'est
effectivement une des missission
principale qu'il a eu durant durant ces
9 ans d'exercice et je vous le disait
nous aurons plus d'informations sur son
départ et sur l'arrivée de son
remplaçant ce proche de Vincent payant
dans les prochains jour le
vice-président du conseil général des
ivelines est donc l'invité de cette
première partie du 78 il est question du
super métro le Grand Paris
Express lancé par le précédent
gouvernement il sera bien mis en place
assure la nouvelle ministre en charge du
dossier Cécile Duflot seulement le délai
sera plus long c'est une certitude le
gouvernement rendra ses décisions le 15
février en attendant c'est le rapport du
haut fonctionnaire Pascal osanet qui
fait parler rapport sur le calendrier de
réalisation sur le financement également
du projet Ivan deal vous représentez le
Conseil Général des yvelin au comité
stratégique de la Société du Grand Paris
qui doit intervenir pour réaliser ce ce
dossier quelle est votre réaction
surtout lorsque vous avez entendu
c'était m-décembre que les délis
seraient plus longs on parle de 2030
plutôt que 2025 et puis que le coût du
budget le coût global augmenta de 10
milliards d'euros on parle de 30
milliards aujourd'hui oui concernant le
le coût il n'y a pas vraiment de
dérapage par tout même d'une ha milardou
il y a une augmentation du coût mais ça
prend en compte des projets
supplémentaires par exemple l'addition
d'un certain nombre de nouvelles gares
donc c'est pas un dérapage c'est
l'addition d'un certain nombre c'est une
augmentation de la taille du projet donc
le problème porte sur le délai aussi le
la question du rapport aux anné le
rapport aux anné a soulevé un tolé tolé
chez tous les élus il faut le dire à
l'unanimité la le comité stratégique
rassemble des élus de toute l'île- de-
France nous avons
adopté un document à l'issue de de la
Réunion où à l'unanimité nous avons il
faut le dire condamné le rapport aux
Anel pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est qu'il désarticule le réseau
l'intérêt du réseau du Grand Paris
précisément c'est d'avoir un réseau en
boucle avec une grande fluidité du
trafic il nous propose de faire des
morceaux ici et là de façon disparate et
donc on perd tout tout le bénéfice il y
a des choix qui sont fait effectivement
on est plus du tout sur une boucle il y
a que certains tronfons qui ser
R ça devient absurde première première
raison les ensuite il y a le délai qui
est clairement inacceptable tous les
élus savent que la demande elle est là
le besoin est là aujourd'hui et donc on
a besoin de réaliser de toute urgence ce
métro pour satisfaire à la fois les
besoins d'aujourd'hui et de demain la
longueur totale de ce super métro c'est
200 km le grand parier Express c'est un
projet de réseau je le rappelle composé
de quatre lignes de super métro
automatique régional on boucle
normalement autour de Paris en tout cas
c'est ce qui ce qui était prévu au tout
des départ je vais vous citer parce que
vous avez effectivement fait un
communiqué à l'issue de cette
présentation pour vous vous vous nous
précisez que le rapport passe à côté de
l'essentiel la synergie entre les
différents pôles de cluster de synergie
également entre la recherche et
l'innovation concentré plutôt dans la
partie vlinoise et puis la recherche et
l'innovation publique plutôt concentré
pardon dans la partie
onienne pour vous c'est aujourd'hui
séparé il n'y a plus de lien qui va être
assuré et là aussi c'est un problème ben
le parmi les les lignes il y a d'abord
pour nous ce qui nous intéresse plus ici
c'est évidemment la ligne verte qui doit
relier versaill chantier à Orli en
passant par sacly euh cette ligne elle a
d'abord pour but de satisfaire des
besoins d'aujourd'hui euh les réseau
sont les réseaux routiers sont
totalement saturés il faut délester le
RERB a priori 20 % grâce à cette ligne
et puis on en a surtout besoin pour le
succès du cluster de Paris Saclay euh
aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui a
suscité des débats au début aujourd'hui
ilit fait consensus le Premier ministre
l'a redit tout récemment pour le succès
de cette opération il faut qui est
centré sur la recherche et l'innovation
il faut assurer une cohérence de
l'ensemble or c'est un fait de
l'histoire l'essentiel de la recherche
publique se trouve dans les sones h vous
avez Polytechnique le CEA notamment et
l'essentiel de la recherche privée se
trouve dans les ivelines notamment sur
véisie et sa-quentin en Yveline et donc
c'est de la cohérence de cet ensemble
que peut sortir effectivement le le
projet vous avez le sentiment que cette
partie là de la région a été oubliée le
secteur qui n concerne par aujourd'hui
si vous voulez ça figure dans le rapport
aux anné il dit réalisons d'abord un
tronçon entre Massip palzo et puis sa
clé et puis après on verra c'est absurde
on va perdre tout le bénéfice de
l'opération et tous les experts le
savent il y a eu des des études
comparatif sur les grands clusters qui
ont été faits dans le monde tous
considèrent que un point majeur c'est la
qualité de la desserte par les
transports en commun et donc si on ne le
réalise pas cette ligne verte rapidement
on compromet en fait le résultat d'une
opération dans laquelle on a déjà
investi des milliards d'euros le
président du conseil général Alain
Schmid qui dénonce une mission de dupe
pour qualifier donc ce rapport aux
années vous êtes d'accord oui mais je
vous dis je vous l'ai dit il a été
condamné par tous les élus Jean-Paul
Luchon lui-même a dit certains certains
font plus de bruit que d'autres on va
dire en tout cas sur son analyse et sur
sa conclusion jeanuch on partage pas
vraiment les mêmes opinions politiques
jean-pul Luchon président du conseil
régional a déclaré récemment que le
grand P Express n'était pas un luxe mais
un investissement pour effectivement
développer la région île-de-fance et
mieux satisfaire les besoins des
franiliens mais en revanche vous le
citez justement jean-pul Luchon lui
semble plutôt confiant il se dit que
finalement le dossier se fera ce n'est
qu'un rapport pour l'instant rapport aux
années qui doit guider le gouvernement
mais les décisions au final sera rendu
le 15 février c'est un espoir partagé
euh vous restez confiant bah écoutez
j'ai pas de raison aujourd'hui de faire
de de procès d'atention gouvernementn
gvernement Thierry lajois qui est le
conseiller de Cécile Duflot qui est en
charge du dossier a dit lui-même que
c'est un rapport que comme tous les
rapports il pouvait connaître des
fortunes diverses ce que j'espère c'est
qu'il finira rapidement dans les
poubelles de l'Histoire et que le
gouvernement prendra les bonnes
décisions c'est-à-dire de réaliser
rapidement un investissement dont on a
besoin pour développer l'emploi dans la
région mais vous dites rapidement mais
il y a des contraintes techniques aussi
si on gardait par exemple les délis
était fixé au tout début techniquement
il faudrait réaliser 18 km par an c'est
impossible si si si euh non la la
technique AB bond do euh ce est dit
aussi danspp vous allez dans un certain
nombre de pays étrangers je peux vous
dire que c'est pas c'est pas un problème
donc euh la question effectivement c'est
celle du rythme du financement mais
concernant le financement il faut
d'abord dire que les entreprises paient
déjà un service euh qui ne leurit pas
rendu ce qui est quand même un peu
paradoxal qu'ensuite euh c'est 2,6
milliards d'euros sachez quand même que
en Finlande à côté d'alzinki on fait un
Paris saclé local qui s'appelle otagemi
la Finlande et la région la région
d'elzinki c'est à peu près la population
éelinoise ils sont en train de le faire
ce métro pour 800 millions d'euros
est-ce que ce qu'un petit pays comme la
Finlande fait on ne peut pas le faire
dans un grand pays comme la France
attendez vous parlez du coup aussi mais
le coup on est en période de crise je
vous apprends rien forcément les budgets
sont difficiles comment on va financerûr
écoutez çail faut pas faire des
économies quelque part en ce moment oui
mais il faut pas faire les économies sur
ce qui permet de préparer l'avenir euh
si on veut créer la dynamique économique
qui va permettre demain d'avoir des
entreprises d'avoir d'innover et créer
des emplois et ben il faut s'en donner
les moyens et je pense que c'est
l'investissement dont on a besoin de
toute façon il faut le faire et il faut
le faire vite c'est votre message autant
le faire vite ça fera finalement des
économies ça coûtera moins cher que
d'attendre en plus de toute façon les
grands projets plus ça dure plus ça
coûte cher aujourd'hui les taux
d'intérêts mondiaux sont très très bas
ils sont historiquement bas ils seront
couverts par l'inflation très rapidement
et en plus si vous voulez c'est une
vraie mise de fond demain ce sera
remboursé par le travail par la
dynamique des entreprises qui se
créeront à la suite de la création de
ces infrastructures Ivan Deval on va
profiter également de votre présence sur
ce plateau pour évoquer le vote du
budget du Conseil Général des Yvelines
où vous siégez le Conseil Général don a
voté vendredi 21 décembre un budget
primitif 2013
1,277 milliards d'euros c'est son
montant en hausse de 2 % les postes les
plus financés transport et formation
votre regard sur ce budget ben écoutez
d'abord le Conseil Général maîtrise
autant que faire ce peut ses dépenses de
fonctionnement parce que on est
confronté à une à un problème de recette
hein qui est assez général mais nous
voulons aussi maintenir nos
investissements donc on a serré les
dépenses de fonctionnement tout en
satisfaisant les besoins les besoins
c'est d'abord pour 58 % la satisfaction
de besoins sociaux c'est la mission
numéro 1 des conseils généraux pour le
handicap pour les personnes âgées pour
les jeunes
pour les personnes sans emploi le
Conseil Général fait son travail mais
sinon nous avons encore près de 28 % du
budget qui sont voués à
l'investissement et notamment là aussi
on en parlait à l'instant pour créer des
grandes infrastructures de transport on
on est en train d'avancer sur le projet
de tangentiel ouest qui va permettre de
relier saint-sire l'école à
Saint-Germain en lait
RAA ça va faire un maillage et on va
poursuivre et bientôt achever d'ailleurs
en 2014 le tramois de véis le fameux T6
ce tram dont nous parlerons également
puisqu'il sera présenté prochainement
vous aurez l'occasion d'en voir les
images de la réalisation merci vanval
d'être venu sur le plateau pour évoquer
principalement ce Grand Paris Express
verdict du gouvernement le 15 février
vous y serez forcément à attentif et on
refera un point à cette occasion
handicap moteur et vie sexuelle journée
mondiale du braille demain 4 janvier
voici ce qui vous attend dans la suite
du 78 pour l'instant retour sur
l'opération du Secours populaire des
ivelines et qui propose en ce moment à
des familles en difficulté de découvrir
la montagne reportage d'Antony
Resche le jour se lève à peine sur les
rues de trappe et ils sont 13 à avoir la
tête tournée vers les sommets le Secours
populaire organise son premier voyage
intergénérationnel à valorsine en haut
de Savoie au programme initiation de ski
balade en raquette et une visite du
glacier du Montblanc la Mer de Glace
grâce au Père Noël vert du Secours
populaire toute la famille croisé peut
partir en vacances content parce que ça
fait de mois qu'on sait donc comme on
leur a dit dès le début ce qu'on aurait
pas dû faireah ça fait de mois qu'il
nous fatigue avec ça donc sont super
pressés quoi voilà il ou il vont
découvrir c'est vrai que bon la neige un
peu attrape mais bon ça rien à voir avec
un séjour au ski je pense qu'ils vont
être sages en plus mais ils vont
profiter ou il vont bien s'amuser on se
défouler si certains sont déjà équipés
pour la neige la plart skill de quoi
oublier un peu le quotidien et découvrir
d'autres horizons c'est la prière fois
oui j'ai déjà touché de la neige
qu'est-ce que tu veux y faire là-bas la
de laale du
skiire partir un petit peu puis qu'ils
n'ont pas l'occasion de partir en
vacances de pouvoir partager un moment
de de convivialité avec d'autres
familles faire de nouvelles rencontte un
moment d'échange de
partage chargement des bagages une
première photo souvenir avant art pour
valorine retour prévu le 5
janvier